[Music]
foreign
and here are the top three things that
you will get out of this Workshop
so first I will teach you about machine
learning with scikit-learn and then I
will introduce Pi torch for deep
learning both psychic learn and pytorch
are the most widely used machine
learning and deep learning libraries out
there in both Academia and Industry so
you get exposure to the most popular
open source libraries for both machine
learning and deep learning
second you will learn to use these tools
in a professional manner I have
experience in both teaching machine
learning and deep learning classes in a
statistics department and teaching deep
learning and machine learning in
Industry contexts so I will combine
these two strengths where we cover both
the best practices for code
implementations but then also through
this rigorously
third I will also expose you to The
Cutting Edge tools that are currently
being used for instance you are probably
all familiar with large language models
so in this course we will also learn how
we tune and how we use large language
models ourselves which will give you
access to the most latest machine
learning models out there
foreign